okay tell me if you've heard this one
before comedian tells joke audience
laughs and then half the world outside
the Laugh Factory gets them ahold of it
now to the fierce backlash against louis
c.k after nine months out of the
spotlight the disgraced comedian the
disgraced comedian plenty of outrage got
to ask you about the controversy your
joke was offensive Trevor Noah under
fire then comes the half-hearted apology
to save their career there were so many
protests he was forced to publicly
apologize but you apologize I apologize
I had to do it why do you have to do it
was it now it comes a sponsor all the
rest of them have to piggy back and act
righteous to they don't really care
right it's the deal we gotta act
offended Tracy Morgan took the mic to
apologize for his inflammatory comedy
act and when the smoke clears either the
comedian is limping away with a
so-called scandal under their belt or a
completely torpedoed career but why this
is a relatively new phenomenon it used
to be the comedian's where Untouchables
and could say anything they want now you
have comedians regularly locking up cell
phones and walking on eggshells is your
starting point a little bit more sort of
tamer these days
does that hurt your act though yeah
that's way less funny is that right why
this is happening is up for some debate
some say it's call out culture some say
the new generation is too sensitive and
those probably all factored in but I'd
argue there's a more complicated problem
going on a problem of language game
confusion enabled and empowered by the
Internet the concept of language games
was described by the philosopher Vidkun
Stein it's the idea that language is an
interpreted only one way instead
language interpretation is based on the
many different language games we all
unconsciously play which determine the
way we interpret meaning here are a few
language games to think about you and I
play these all the time fluidly
switching between them depending on the
context I mocked up a few of these
language games to illustrate my point if
you put any of them in a different
context they make no sense but within
their language game they're perfectly
sensible understanding which games
someone else is playing is as important
as the words they're using each game has
its own rules grammar and meaning and
because of that misunderstanding their
game can lead to confusion you've had
this experience before when you say no
no I was being sarcastic or I was joking
but now is where we get back to our
story because comedy has its own
language game and these slip-ups
scandals and foe paws occur when people
misunderstand the comedy language game
and I would like to argue that this is
because of the way we decontextualize
things in the media anyone who's been in
a comedy club knows the language game is
set up to be unmistakable its dimly lit
you go to hear comedy expectations are
set and people are drinking
there's even warm-up acts to get you in
the right mood the whole environment
sets you up with a certain expectation
however today people are filming what
goes on in these comedy clubs and
posting it on Twitter and when that
happens things get decontextualized
suddenly a joke is no longer landing two
drinks and it's no longer couched
between two other jokes two may be
softer jokes a joke now sits below a CBS
news piece on social media you lose
these pre-agreed language games so when
louis c.k says some stuff about
snowflake ii kids the people watching
the clip live see a joke they laugh
these kids are not in a suit saying I'm
here to tell you not interesting because
he went to a high school where kids got
shot what does that mean I have a listen
to you
but the internet had a very different
reaction they see an angry old man and
read into his act a malicious unfeeling
undertone but that's because the whole
Act has been decontextualized to the
Internet where it sits alongside
political debates and internet trolls
and this can happen anytime you take a
joke and put it in a context where the
language game isn't clear
John Mulaney recounts how insane his
jokes sound when they're read seriously
never goes well they're like and that's
why you shouldn't give to charity that's
something you find funny mr. Mulaney the
old saying turns out to be true if you
have to explain a joke it isn't funny
anymore you've dragged it out of the
context where it made sense this sharp
disconnect between people who see a
comedy bit in its proper context and
people who see it online has become a
common complaint among comedians like
the amount of times they've shown clips
they'll be like come on Traverse lis got
the last laugh Turing and though they
show the bit and the whole crowd laughed
right there next thing you know you're
on a split screen you're sitting there
talking to a blogger comedians no the
risk of misunderstanding and avoiding
this language game misinterpretation has
become part of the craft this is why
some people take up cell phones to
prevent recording but this is just a way
to avoid the source of the problem that
the Internet makes it easier than ever
to misinterpret jokes as if they're
serious which is why we the public need
to remember this the context of the
original statement matters if the bit
was in a comedy club on stage
your default interpretation should be
that they were joking no matter what is
said or how funny anyone thinks it is it
was a joke it might have been a bad joke
but it was a joke just because you took
what I said seriously doesn't mean I now
meant it like if I'm saying something
and I'm joking I'm joking I just want
somebody to just go it's a joke I'm not
apologizing
thanks for watching that video that was
sort of a mini coffee break I'm in them
in a little bit big project right now
and I just wanted to get something out
to you also if you're looking for more
coffee break content go check out the
second channel I have a hilarious series
called fake gurus that I'm doing right
now that's been a lot of fun so go take
a look at that and yeah just subscribe
share if you want and I will see you
guys soon
[Music]